foreign
[Music]
finally yeah after you put pants on he's
like what time is like why is he getting
modest now because he did the show
Wednesday night in his underwear
that was like my wrestling outfit yeah
that's what Mark said it's no different
than a pro wrestler
oh I felt kind of bad about it but it
was because because I was just like oh
man we're talking about like
some kind of bummer [__] and it's like
it sounds like running around his
underwear it was it was funny though so
I can't be too mad at it
it's a princess guy show wouldn't it
yeah it was yeah yeah
that was a long time ago yeah it's still
terrible but it's a long time ago uh but
yeah so hey everybody and thank you very
much for all the congratulations uh yeah
in case we I mean in case you weren't
here Wednesday night when Tom spilled
beans uh and in case you didn't see the
Facebook posts we got married yesterday
you have to live together for 13 years
yeah well this is uh yeah
I just I thought it was funny I posted
it on on Facebook
and we got um I think I got a
120 something comments with most people
with like a lot of them was finally yeah
yeah we had several of those about time
God damn
that's that's what a lot of them were
yeah I have to say but uh but yeah the
pictures came out cute you know yeah
but you know
yeah uh oh hey Zach yeah he's going on a
date tonight and I said
um so we can't save for the show so I
said well you have to tell us all the
sort of details like later on yeah
I'll take him to the um to the bath
house
at least at least take him to dinner
first it's gonna be in the [__]
bubble bath listening to the Gavin
Friday Vlad is a champagne and condoms
I know how you guys are
I would kind of like that it sounds like
kind of fun to be licking the bottom of
each other's feet and [__] playing feet
games what yeah where did that come from
it's good
they [__] play with feet and [__]
that's okay yeah
laughs
[Laughter]
yeah Zach says nope it's me and the BF
and his sassy black friend because every
gay needs at least one that's true okay
uh and we getting dinner okay okay
she might end up in the bath house
though
in a satanic threesome it's not the
devil's threesome it's a satanic
oh my God damn yeah
yeah so I yeah I'm just I'm reading all
the comments Trey says Hey married
couple congrats guys thank you very much
Camp guy says very happy for you both
y'all are great together oh thank you
very much uh and then Tammy said you
have to have a laugh or two during those
kind of shows or it's too much of a
bummer that's what I figure it's just
kind of like I read the line between
it's like man we're talking about serial
killers and death and [__] like that and
then we're like making all these jokes
and but then I'm like yeah [__] it like
I said it's too much of a bummer if
you're just like serious about it all
the time
um and Trey said when the show first
started I told them part of what makes
it good is that they're such a great
couple guys yeah thank you yeah yeah we
have our moments
[Music]
we're really thinking about it
yeah well she just cut it just had
natural
that's what yeah Tom likes to say that
too he's like kind of I don't even think
we I don't think we ever even had any
point in our relationship where we said
oh this is like we're a thing now
because what I mean we kind of did but
we just kind of like
it just wandered it wandered it it
didn't make sense not to start [__]
each other
and then you just started moving in yeah
save some money
yeah we didn't really have we were
hanging out all the time anyway so we
did houses we didn't like have a big
talk about it or anything like that
that's kind of like um
I don't know we kind of do everything
that way honestly a lot of good there's
a lot of relationship advice out there a
lot of it bad
relationship the the
when it comes to relationship there
there's got to be more than just kind of
like
sexual attraction you got to have [__]
in common yeah and it's good if you're
working on a task together me and Jim
were always doing stuff having to do
with the club
Club promotions trying to
find out [__] different ways of
making money or making a name for
ourselves
you know this has even happened back
before we were a thing we were trying to
do [__] together yeah so
there has to be more of a foundation
than just like superficial [__]
yeah yeah I mean a lot a lot of dudes
will just [__] and women same thing
will just jump on the first hot thing
that they see but then they get married
it turns out too late that they don't
have anything in common
that they don't even really like each
other
yeah so it's best if you marry somebody
from the ranks of like friends and [__]
and I'm not you know not just speaking
from ignorance
I did a lot of dating man I was married
before too she was married before yeah
yeah and uh I got a [__] pretty high
body count
so I know
yeah I know the way it happens
yeah lots of times yeah
the average woman you know
problem you know but the average dude
you know there's not much to him either
so average dude also problem
a lot of it a lot of their problems are
[__] self-created because they can't
open their [__] eyes
Kevin says where's the best place to ask
you personal questions
well you can ask them here depending on
how personal are you talking about yeah
because I mean
there's there's not much that I can
think of that we wouldn't answer on here
but you know because she was outrageous
we just laugh at it yeah and then be
like a message me later but if it's not
if it's just like a regular ass personal
question I don't care
about about answering it here we don't
we don't have any secrets from people
I'm waiting I'm waiting for uh Sheehan
order supposed to be showing up it's got
three pairs of Jenny's new it's her it
was her birthday yeah like early
birthday yeah birthday package I ordered
for but it's got a lot of good [__] in
it I don't want her to wait for her
birthday I wonder if I can get it soon
he's like I want to see you wearing all
that [__] three pair of shoes and a New
Dress yeah
yeah the dress is uh
it's um kind of like one of the uh it's
kind of like one of the uh the fairy
core dresses but it's black but yeah I
think he's got skulls or bats on it it's
a Gothic version of it yeah it's nice
and um
some gloves in there with cat claws on
them
remember that yeah that's right close
the claws sorry I spaced out for a
second yeah yeah
because that while I was reading uh I
was reading a comment at the same time
and I was like what yeah I thought you
went smart-hearted on me
oh it's yeah I can't help but I can't
help it
yeah I invented that word to describe
myself smart tarded yeah I told that to
my mom and she laughed her ass off she
was like yep you nailed it I'm like I
know I did she'll just walk around hit
her head on a limb
walking to a pole yeah
I'm telling you man I'm in a car door
and [__] hit her knee oh I know I
know I hit myself in the nose yeah yeah
that's what I did the other day two days
ago we were going to the store and I
opened the car door and just hit myself
right in the [__] face and like left
a big V like right I'm like that that's
smooth only I would do that my
motorcycle friends are astounded that
when I was going to bike night that you
weren't riding with me right yeah
because he would go and like talk about
her about me and they'd be like where's
she at then yeah I saw I met a couple of
them when we were at mannequins because
some of them hang out in front of
mannequins like on Friday nights when we
go but there was like well why don't you
ride and I'm like nobody needs me riding
a motorcycle trust me I I almost I'm a
public health I tried to teach her
but then I was like 10 minutes into it I
was like no I'm surprised I can even
drive a car to be honest with you it
took me a long time to learn it yeah and
the longer I knew the more I realized
that uh no she doesn't need to be on a
motorcycle no I don't it's like I said I
I would either kill myself or kill
others you know for
motorcycle you have to have at least
some modicum of mind and machine
connection
Jenny has a hard time with Mind Body
Connection I do yeah so I'm kind of
don't be very mechanical and a very
mechanical Rider
and very dangerous
yeah because there's no time to think
about any of that mechanically yeah I've
had [__] happen to me like losing my
front end in a turn that means your
front tire starts sliding away from you
and got out of it and I don't know how I
did it
got out of it that's one of the most
dangerous things I was going through an
intersection went across the center of
the intersection there's a pile of sand
there all the cars had pushed up over
time
front tire hit that sand patch slid
probably about two feet
and it regained traction but I
I don't know it happened so fast it just
felt like hitting something
you know that was straight up and down
again
but I was losing the bike
well there can't there has to be a good
mind Motor Machine connection you can't
there's no time to think it's instant
reactions yeah and I've had some [__]
just been startled the [__] out of me
and got out of it and I'm not quite sure
exactly what happened or how I got out
of it but my body knew and did it
without thinking
he's just trying to keep the bike riding
down the road straight I always wished I
had that yeah but I never and like I
said I took dance when I was younger and
I was good at that but it's just kind of
like other than that I'm just like I
don't know what my [__] problem is
I'm just flailing around like yeah like
I don't know what yeah Zach said I'm
also a hazard Jenny I'll lose balance
for literally no reason when I'm just
standing still same same I do that as
well I have trouble like when I'm
seriously where I'm just walking up and
down the stairs of our house I'm like
hanging on like going a little one step
at a time because I'm just like oh my
God I'm gonna fall I'm gonna fall I'm
gonna fall okay Kevin's like uh personal
question was about Xi'an and undies oh
see that's not that personal yeah that's
not personal like I said I can't really
think of much of anything that I
wouldn't answer well I don't want to say
that you didn't answer his questions
though well no he's just asking about
undies I don't know what that I don't
know what the actual question is yeah
like
like have I bought undies from Xi'an yes
I bought some cool uh
skull well they have like skulls and
[__] and they're like and then they have
like white they're kind of black and
gray and then they have white lace
around the outside and they're kind of
thongy if you're asking about the men's
selections the men's selection there is
just kind of boring
yeah they have like way more like cool
women's clothes than they do men's
clothes like Tom got some shirts there
the other day they were that were pretty
good good but yeah then I
I [__] decided to order a size
smaller in the ones that I did they were
a little big they were they felt I mean
they were supposed to be mediums but
they were a little big they looked big
they did shrink when we ran them through
the laundry not enough though oh thank
you very much Titanic discussion thank
you thank you greetings everyone do you
folks have any good drive-in theater
stories oh I'm lucky enough to oh I'm
sure Tom does yeah he's no he's heard my
stories yeah I'm lucky enough to have a
classic one right near me hasn't changed
since 1957. have a great night thank you
very much that's very nice of you yeah
mine um honestly I think the drive-in
theater was
I didn't go there much like as a
teenager because I think it was mostly
kind of
sketchy at that time
I went there a lot as a kid like my
parents would take us but
I remember going there one night and
they were doing like an all night
overnight thing and this was in Daytona
so it was like on the corner of Nova
Road and Hand Avenue I think it was and
um so they were doing an all night thing
and for some reason and I could be
totally remembering this wrong
but they're like we're gonna do five
movies and it's like all night and you
can like camp out you know what I mean
we were like so excited we brought like
snacks and blankets and [__] like that
and um so we go there and a couple of
the movies were just like normal I think
they were kind of like just comedies but
then one of the movies was scanners
and like so they did like a comedy and
then maybe another comedy and then
scanners and then so we're watching it
and then literally what like five
minutes into that movie that dude's head
explodes yeah and my mom was like but
okay we're going and I was like ah
I don't remember how old
well that's probably not if it was
scanners nine or ten
oh that's funny
Tammy said I love being on the back of
the bike holding on to my man but I
would never try and drive one I don't
like I don't like riding two up yeah
motorcycle I have ridden on his bike
before but it's it kind of makes me
nervous too but the two that I have
right now that that are good enough for
her for her to ride on with me or
they're two buells and they're very
small large bore liquid or uh air-cooled
push rod V twins they're basically
basically sport bikes with
Harley-Davidson engines in them
and they're uh there's not much of a
tail so she's sitting on the back
there's not a lot there's not much there
she'd be sitting on a little eight inch
[__] piece of [__] dick right
there and uh the other uh the 1200 that
I have has been race modified with the
fiberglass solo race seat in it so it
can only take one
uh but the my nine I got a Buell
xb9xs city cross
and it's got a custom seat on it too and
it's not really meant for two uh
but those bikes are small they're like
the size of them
250.
maybe smaller than 250 closer to like a
125 what a huge [__] engine in it
very short
wheelbase
if you put a bunch of weight on the tail
you the steering starts getting a little
crazy it's not a good motorcycle for
passengers yeah or cool riders now they
made it that took that bike and they had
a stretched version of it called a
Ulysses the SS was also kind of
stretched they were they they had I
think they had a little more rake on the
front end and a and um
the wheelbase was bigger by several
inches it felt a lot more natural with a
with a co-writer on it because the bike
felt bigger bills feel real small they
do yeah the I mean the few times that I
wrote on the back with you it was
terrifying because I just felt like I
didn't have any room in that I was just
gonna fly off the back even when you
weren't going that fast yeah
you're riding a bike and you're sitting
up on the bike and you don't see a
motorcycle
we got to look down to see the front
wheel and the instruments and everything
it's just real tightly packed
and they don't you know about a hundred
horse
but it's 85 foot-pounds of torque
all of it [__] and it makes like
I think it makes sense I think that's
probably him that's probably see him I
think it makes the ice maker it sounded
like it was that way oh I can't I can't
tell where this is coming from you're
being smart harder to get it
it was um no I'm deaf yeah that's
another thing just at idle uh those
bills make about 60 horse 60 foot pounds
of torque it's just a torque monster
they're not fast but they're very quick
you know they'll top out at 135 or 145
miles an hour depending on which one it
is
but they'll run with a Hayabusa from a
dead stop for about about an eighth of a
mile dude I've actually left Hayabusas
behind me then they they rest eventually
they spool up and catch up to you and
outrun you because it's they're you know
they got four cylinders and it's liquid
cooled but higher compression it's just
a fun bite they got real good handling
and they're little and
strong and they've put out a lot of
power without put a lot of torque
without even really burning much fuel in
a real low RPM
like that kind of like riding around on
a [__] diesel or something I like
your sound effects
[Laughter]
yeah murder Hornet said love the blue
wig thank you very much this is my
favorite wig actually this is actually
my second one that I have exactly like
this the first one I wore it so much
that it got all like tangly and yucky
looking
so I had to uh buy another one and it
probably this is probably gonna get
tangly and yucky look into so I'm
probably gonna buy another one I just
got it from Amazon they're not expensive
it was 18 20 or something like that
uh yeah Camp guy said my mother was
always definitely afraid of motorcycles
so I never learned to enjoy them when I
was a kid yeah I just my dad had one
uh when I was growing up because he was
real into the the biker lifestyle and uh
so he had a Harley he had some other
ones and my mom like very expressly told
him it's like you know the kids cannot
ride on the back of the bike even though
we kind of wanted to there's a picture
of me and my brother I was probably
eight and my brother was probably four I
imagine like somewhere around there and
we are sitting on my dad's motorcycle
like on my grandma's front porch and
like my little brother has like this my
dad's helmet on a [__] it's a cute
picture
but yeah I still remember that picture
but um yeah so we never really wrote on
the back of the bikes and I was always
kind of scared to but then when I was 14
I think I was about 14 I was in junior
high and my dad for whatever reason I
don't remember how I usually got to
school I think like they usually took me
in the car or something like that but um
because I didn't take the bus but my Dad
decided that he was gonna take me to
school on the back of his motorcycle and
somehow my mom didn't know about it she
must have been at work or something so I
didn't really want to but I was just
kind of like okay and so I got on the
back of the motorcycle I don't remember
what kind of motorcycle it was and it
was like it was terrifying
and I was just kind of like holy [__] I
don't really want to do this anyway it's
like I said I was like 13 or 14 years
old and then he gets me to the school
and I think I said this before he didn't
tell me that you have to get off on a
certain side like to avoid burning your
leg on the tailpipe so I got off on the
wrong side and I burned my leg on the
tailpipe
and um well they don't I didn't notice
it I had to get off motorcycle for I
didn't I didn't notice it for a long
time until I was like in class later
because I didn't feel it at the time and
then I looked at my leg and it was just
like this huge blister it was actually
like a second degree burn I had a scar
for years and years it's gone now but
co-writers will instinctively when
they're on the back of the bike and
their feet are sitting on the on the
co-rider pegs because there's no
passengers they have to co-ride with you
all right passengers are car that's car
action all right you gotta have Body
English to even be a co-writer on a
motorcycle anyway they'll be sitting on
the back they try to get off so they
just slide down they take their foot off
the Peg and put it on the ground right
where the pipe is and they'll burn their
foot yeah I mean I was a kid and nobody
told me right
you never do that you're supposed to
stand up on the pegs swing your leg
around the [__] saddle and come down
and you can use the opposite leggings I
know that now yeah but my dad did not
tell me yeah you don't and I was just
like I said I was just like a 14 or
something like that so
I don't know and my mom was so mad when
she saw that when she saw that uh burn
because it was awful and like I said it
left a scar for years and years I had
this huge like um oval shaped scar it
was really gross like on the inside of
my calf
murder Hornet said Tom I sent you some
Trend LOL yeah right
not again okay he wanted uh um
it's [__] funny anyway uh he wanted
the drive-in stories I know what he's
talking about yeah tell us some driving
stories like I said that's the only good
one I have because we did what we went a
lot but not when I was a teenager when I
was like yeah his grandfather's here I
don't think so I haven't seen him unless
he's just like lurking me me and me and
grampers went to high school together
and uh in Michigan I did uh I think two
years in Michigan and three years in
Brazil
because I think I got held back by one
year for losing credits though like from
moving from one school yeah my Brazilian
School wouldn't accept American credits
yeah they'll do that and uh
if I remember correctly maybe I didn't
might have only been I think I might
have maybe it just made it I graduated
in 87. that may have been on time
I just I just might be remembering it
funny I think I thought I was going to
have to do it an extra year maybe yeah
because you're I graduated in 1990 and
you're three years older than me so that
makes sense okay yeah yeah I was afraid
I think they ended okay I think they
ended up giving me the credits so I did
two and two I think
or maybe I only did one year in uh in
Michigan
I think I did too
yeah see what happens when you get older
yeah yeah yeah I can't remember a lot of
[__] from back then either
anyway this is in Trenton Michigan
and me and my my [__]
uh best friend Steve Rouse we were to
drama together grandpars was Andromeda
too
Steve was getting all the damn leads and
I was getting all like the top
supporting roles
we could sing and Steve came from a band
you know he could play bass he knew
music theory and everything he loved
[__] Pink Floyd and
[__] Iron Maiden and stuff so he was
very talented and he was also like a
straight A student he was [__] taken
[__] I could only dream of taking he was
taking like chemistry too and [__]
calculus and [__] I had a problem
getting past Algebra I said Calculus
what's that I said calculus yeah well
aren't you smart in high school yeah but
he was taking care he was taking all
this [__] anyway he was uh
me and Steve are getting all the girls
basically
and uh we were tearing them up and uh
not literally tearing it yeah
figuratively yeah
yeah
well we had a drive in there and a
drive-in was it was the teenage Motel
yeah it just drove down there and that's
[__] you saw that in in Greece yeah
it was a lot cheaper it was much it's a
lot cheaper than [__] getting a motel
room they probably would you probably
wouldn't rent it to you being underage
so you would no probably not you pull in
there and you could tell who was [__]
who he's driving through and you're
looking along the back line of the
[__] the very back of the damn
driving
there's Jason's car yeah we know who
he's with you know and the then it was
like wow these little ass cheeks coming
up yeah
[Laughter]
well we go to these things so we'd be
double dating you know I'd have my date
and he'd had his date
man one thing leading I mean I don't
know I guess I was raised wrong anyway I
was raised wrong
although I feel like most people did
that yeah
I don't know man I think me and Steve
the tag team same girl at the same time
too well you know uh we just be like the
thing is is that you know he date her
one day and I dated the other they
weren't girlfriends right they were
girls that we were both dating yeah we
would date a bunch of them
and uh sometimes you know he I'd be in
the back seat with my date and he'd be
in the front seat with his date and we'd
be [__] throwing down the girls are
talking to each other [__] sharing
cigarettes across the top of the back
being [__] Steve [__] high-fiving
it's just wild man the 80s were good was
a good time real good
uh according to statistics
we were a lot more sexually active than
teenagers of today evidently
the ones that they have like hookup
culture and [__] but yeah we just did it
differently we were screwing people we
knew yeah and went to school with you
know
it's a lot better when you know them
yeah
I mean I feel like maybe it's a lot less
dangerous too because nowadays I think
people are still like hooking up but
they're just like met him online or
something and if you wanted to be a
player if you wanted to be a player in
that game
you had to you had to be Charming you
had to be good with these women
or they wouldn't come back or they
wouldn't tell you or they would tell
them yeah they would tell everybody else
right
no man
Grandpa's always asking about the secret
basement [__] we had it we had a
lounge
and it was a [__] professionally
built [__] Lounge down in Steve's
mom's basement we make out down in there
man
smoke weed [__] drop acid do I gotta
listen to music
one of our friends would be over me and
Steve and [__] jump on her and just
start making out with her if it was like
well let's send this chick to the Moon
you know
and light her up
and love you know
well yeah then two days later she comes
back she's got a friend with her yeah
right yeah and then someone started
monopolize they're trying to take over
we got a roster you know you got to go
back to the line again now we just we
weren't that creative like we would like
to take advantage of your services yeah
yeah these women are like
try her you know so they were recruiting
each other to come hang out with us but
you see we were real cool
yeah you know well yeah you guys weren't
dicks
you know we talk I mean I don't know I
didn't know you back then but I'm saying
um you didn't see no we weren't dicks
yeah
we talk about music and philosophy and
talk about you know gossip about certain
[__] at school and
um you know just
[__] drop ass and talk about Timothy
Leary would do whatever just you know
whatever was called for you know
and uh
just out of that out of that [__] big
furball all kinds of wild [__] happened
I can't even cover it all not even in
one show but it wouldn't make any
difference because y'all don't know the
people if you know them it's a lot
better I think the reason probably that
you always did well with women like I
said was because you didn't come across
like I mean you're not desperate no
you're not kind of like you go out with
a chick and he's like ah this didn't
really work out you don't really care
yeah I mean it's not that you don't care
but it's just kind of like eh yeah well
Jen seen me chase chase girls off the
dance floor for not knowing how to dance
get out of here you know
they're just you know
just [__] like that but um we'll see I
don't understand that it's like there's
plenty of room to just stand if you're
gonna stand or if you're just gonna or
if you're gonna like dork around you
know what I mean with your [__]
purses and whatnot well you know those
girls just get laid by being cute they
don't have to do anything right so
there's no there's nothing there see
some of us had to work harder they gotta
work harder because we weren't as cute
when we were younger yeah honestly I
like cute girls but I also expect cute
girls to be
not worth it
a lot of times you know drama a lot of
them are being skilled
because they don't have to try to do
anything well I think starfish on you
they tend not to be very good in bed
well I think that a lot of good looking
people in general especially if they
were good looking from a young age and
everybody told them how good looking
they were yeah a lot of times they'll
Coast on that not everybody because I
knew some like really really good
looking people that also were super
smart and super accomplished we've got
friends like that yeah we have friends
like that that are just like gorgeous
but they're like but they can really do
[__] too and also real friendly and like
humble they're not snotty at all yeah
but you would think you'd look you'd
look at like you would look at Laura
that's what I was thinking about yeah
you'd look at Laura Ross she's not no
relation to me but we have the same last
name yeah that was that was what she
commented on the things she's like Hey
we're all Ross's now yeah yeah
Laura was like uh
what I was gonna say
[Laughter]
if you see if you were to see Laura at
the club you would think she was snotty
dude girl that pretty's got to be
[__] snot because she is [__] like
ridiculously beautiful she looks like
she's a Carter ridiculously yeah yeah
yeah I'll show a picture in a bit I mean
I think we have before but yeah but she
was like ridiculously beautiful yeah if
you were to see her you'd think she's
not no she's just super sweetheart and
she's super cool yeah she's really
really into her and her boyfriend Adam
are really into cosplay and so they go
to all the conventions and they always
come up with like the coolest [__]
costumes if you guys saw like some of
you guys might have seen this because
the picture went viral and I thought it
was so funny because I saw people we
didn't know like posting it I was like
oh my God it's Laura and Adam but um
they did you know from Superman too yeah
the villains like all inside there they
did the thing they like she dressed up
as what's her face and then Adam dressed
up as uh the one with the beard
yeah and then they had a friend that
dressed up like the other one and they
went around and they built this thing
that looked like you know what I mean
that looked like the the pain of glass
and they all went like that it was so
[__] awesome and that picture that
they took at the I don't remember what
convention it was it might have been
Spooky Empire or whatever it was
um but it went viral and it's like every
time I saw it it would just like make me
laugh because it's like oh my God it's
Lauren Adam
it was just so funny but yeah they
always they go like all out like coming
up with these outfits and like the [__]
they come up with is just [__] great
they also did a variation of that like
the last time where they did like the um
you know the all of the villains from
Superman too but they were inside of a
Barbie box like a life-size Barbie doll
box instead of like in the thing all
right I want the redhead right there
that's gin that's me and that's Laura
it's blurry it's blurry it's blurry very
very blurry
just go slow go slow the red hair that's
gin and below is Laura
and then the other one with black hair
at the bottom is also the other Laura no
that's Jen actually yeah they have the
gin yeah yeah we're all Jen's here
they're all Jazz look but here oh my
phone's ringing
that's not the dude is it I don't go
shoot no I think it says telemarketer
but I can't really see it from here hold
on I gotta answer my phone it's a little
late for that dude that's what I was
thinking it's like not
who it is
yeah it says telemarketer yeah I like
that they have that that's that's a
picture of Laura just with regular
clothes yeah yeah all right
she's awesome I love her yeah
another good picture of Laura
she's just a sweetheart too
well the real thing and like and like I
said I think and not without reason I
guess but like a lot of people do have a
perception that if somebody's like
really pretty or like really beautiful
that they're gonna be like super [__]
but that is not always the case
it is sometimes the case yeah
I had a guy that I was dating tell me
that one time what's that that um that
he's like
he's like you know um you're not for for
a pretty you're not like a pretty girl
and I said you mean I'm not a [__] and
he's like yeah that's what I meant he's
like that's exactly what I meant
I just thought that was really funny
because there is a perception that they
will be a [__] but like I said we know
a lot of
very good looking people that are not
[__]
but you know but but I do think we're
not ugly girls that are [__] too
though well that's straight yeah and
that is also true
I don't think you can tell what a [__]
looks like just from one day because
some pretty girls are [__] and some
ugly girls are [__] too yeah it just
kind of goes you never can across the
board you never can't tell but like I
said that's why you got to know
everybody you can't you can't make
assumptions
longer than you yeah you have yeah yeah
I've known Laura probably maybe 18 years
she was a kid when I met her yeah well
yeah because she's I think she's only in
her 30s yeah maybe late mid to late 30s
yeah
I think I thought she was 36 or 37. yeah
it was one of the first people she met
when she started showing up to the club
I guess I was 38 at the time and I think
she was probably about 18 or 19. yeah
yeah I wonder if she's coming out
tonight I don't know she was at the last
Memento yeah
yeah and what's funny is that she hasn't
changed a bit no she looks exactly the
same
exactly the same
but yeah it's crazy
um yeah so yeah we are going to Memento
tonight so let's see how that goes we
don't know how it's gonna go because
after we told everybody on Facebook so
what's I don't know if they're gonna do
anything but I'm gonna go check them
maybe not
you're gonna go check oh yeah check
packages yeah yeah we have that um
package that's supposed to be coming
but it says it's out for delivery but
we don't know where it's at we don't
know where it's at
uh Sebastian says watched Red Rock West
a good film I haven't heard of that
actually what's it about is it like what
kind of movie is it
um
yeah what was I gonna say I was gonna
say something else
but yeah we I mean and we kind of talk
about this a lot too I do kind of feel
like people that were real good looking
when they were younger
they could um get away with [__] a lot
more because they you know they were
good looking so people would like let
them slide
so they're like I'll just Coast on this
for a while
but then when you start getting older
and
not looking as cute anymore you gotta
have something to fall back on that's
what I always figured so in a way I'm
always kind of glad that I didn't
really I wasn't
um I wasn't ugly when I was a well I was
I was a cute kid you know what I mean
but then like I was a teenager I was
still like oh I was I think I was okay
looking but I was like kind of heavy so
I was kind of chubby you know what I
mean kind of chubby and kind of shy and
bookish and that doesn't usually
translate into popularity as you guys
know
so I feel like I didn't really like
I didn't really come into myself until
probably my late 30s I feel like
you know well you got kind of weighed
down in other situations as things went
on well that too that too
I feel like I didn't really get my [__]
together until I got divorced you know
what I mean
when I was 38 or however old I was
man this thing is still
not here
well by this point it might not be
I mean if it hasn't come by the time we
leave at 9 30 then I don't know what to
tell you
who's tracking I think they did that
[__] before where they said it was out
for delivery and then like ah never mind
never mind
Tammy says uh Jenny did you see it says
it's out for delivery well I know but it
said that before
um did you see Eddie Izard is in a movie
playing Jekyll and Hyde yes I did see
that and I will definitely watch that I
will definitely watch that
because man we love some Eddie izart
murder Hornet didn't really send you any
Trend did he no
[Laughter]
no more trend
well I I do
I think that there was some good that
came out of it I will say that
but
in the aggregate
uh it wasn't a good experience but there
was some good that came out of it I
thought
you know Trends not worth it yeah I
don't think so either no I don't think
so either no you must just do MPP or
deca
which is the same thing just a different
just a different ester of net of
naturalum
I'm just excited because the [__] that
I'm on now is finally doing something
well I said I'm just excited because
what yeah
um I'm just excited because the [__]
that I'm on now is finally doing
something oh yeah
because you're doing something too well
I know that but even even before it's
just I feel like other stuff I was on
was not really doing anything much of
anything yeah just you just gotta
[__] find the right the right one
yeah
you didn't do you didn't do well on DHT
derivatives no I did not yeah 19 North
testosterone that's what that worked
with her yeah that should this [__] is
doing good
burning fast making my legs skinny yeah
that's
what's also diet and training it's
everything well that's you but I'm just
saying that it's like it seems like
it's happening really quick you know
what I mean yeah
well
the DHT derivative stuff and
testosterone derivative you can't give a
female very much of that your
masculinizer yeah
19 North testosterones stuff like NPP or
deca
is uh
not as uh
androgenic as testosterone so you can
give them more
without having to worry about making
them grow beards and [__] like that so
not only is it I mean if you were to
look at it if you look at those those
two compounds side by side
they both look like testosterone but 19
North testosterone has carbons in a
different position
it's not more anabolic than testosterone
it's probably about the same just that
it's a lot less androgenic it's only
like 40 percent
of what test is so you can give a woman
more
and give you more natural loan you can't
test thank you Victor oh my gosh that's
so awesome thank you so much says
congrats my friend thank you very much
it was a long time coming yeah I think
everyone was kind of simple well I was
kind of surprised to be honest
[Laughter]
he just kind of randomly brought it up
yeah we need to get married we were just
um I guess it was like not not this past
weekend but I think was it this past
weekend we haven't no we were like
coffee yeah we were sitting at the
coffee shop yeah I don't even remember
what we were talking about but he just
kind of like started bringing it up I
just said something happens to me I feel
like I get killed then the [__] you
won't be able to
keep the house or get anything out of it
so we might as well get married so you
can get my survivor benefits and things
and I was just like are you [__]
serious no
that's like well [__] we've been
together 13 years already yeah I don't
really see us [__] going and go apart
in ways or anything doesn't matter I'm
not going anywhere you forget I'm gonna
hit the date of the market at 65. you
know this is I told you he's stupid you
know if we break up we'd be just hang
out as roommates
we probably even some of those
[__] it's like even if we did
break up which we're not but if even if
we did I'd be like well I still got to
hang out with you though yeah everybody
else everybody else we know that broke
up still hangs out with each other I
know
so because I just I can't imagine you
not like being around right you know
what I mean well as I said you know
that's my relationship advice
if I can only get involved with women
who are friends of yours they're not
friends of yours they're really now I'm
not saying don't touch it seriously
don't take it seriously you know there's
a lot of women out there just the
chemistry that you have with them is
purely physical and it's very very short
term and that doesn't mean you know that
as a man you should walk away from that
you should at least give her a chance
try her out
[Laughter]
ride the wheels off of it because she's
offered you know and if it Fizzles and
you [__] it you just you know just don't
spend much money on it
well you got some women out there
want money for it you know they're not
even hookers and they want money for it
I don't understand it
you got to get something
all this [__] that I talk I [__]
basically have never been on a date
hahaha
well the dates are for Sims man it
doesn't really it doesn't really it
never really works out like that you
know what I mean
the last one I went on was with [__]
Kristen
a lot before you [__] 13 14 years ago
it was terrible it's like a job
interview and I don't even I don't
dislike Christian I like Kristen but it
just I don't know who that is
Tracy Brown's friend played Minnie Mouse
that uh
at uh remember Tracy and her little
friend yeah
yeah her little friend I dated her I
know but I don't remember her name being
Kristen though Kristen Cavanaugh
oh I don't I don't remember that that's
her name I don't remember that I don't
remember you ever telling me about that
name because I don't remember that name
only Whenever there wants yeah well I'm
just saying I don't remember that name
I'm just saying yeah that's who it was
you remember the girl though I probably
would if I saw her but I don't remember
Tracy Brown of course okay but you were
her little friend that was even smaller
than her no
how long ago was that before I met you
okay so that was a long time but she's
around I remember Tracy because Tracy's
always around and she's dating Ernie
yeah long time before that but also she
has a little friend that shows up every
now and then and that's okay and that's
her
it was like a job interview it was like
a job interview
yeah and I'm just like I know this chick
from the club why am I getting all this
[__] job interview
like Normie you know what I mean so I
just entertained it for a little while
and [__] says all right well yeah
I'll talk to you later I never called
her back I mean I can't hang with that
kind of it's just too much
it's too weird it's the framework is
two-faced yeah I was like why'd she ask
me to meet her for this job interview at
a mall
you know what I mean
at the mall yeah I went to the mall I
went to where she that's where she
wanted to meet me okay
yeah at the mall but you know so I just
said no to it based on the fact that she
had me go meet her at a mall
and go through a [__] job interview
I don't know like I said that's this
ain't a date man yeah you know in my
mind
the dates [__] at the club
or in the parking lot out back behind it
that's the day you know what I mean
getting to know each other yeah I'm not
a sip okay this isn't gonna go down like
this we're gonna have fun you know
but they
I don't know I don't know Tom doesn't
know I don't know he's too old for this
[__] I'm too old for this [__] I don't
care I was too old for that [__] when I
was like 17 18.
I was way too old for that well yeah I
don't like I said I don't really have
much patience for that kind of thing
yeah
um that's kind of why
I like it better like how our [__]
turned out because
we just kind of hung out because we hung
out
we liked each other we had musical uh
mutual friends and [__] like that and
then it's just stuff kind of yeah and it
just kind of like evolved into [__] like
we just started hanging out more and
more and it's just like we didn't really
like think about it or talk about it it
wasn't yeah we didn't have to like put a
parameters on it or like a label on it
or anything like that
I've been seeing these women on Tick
Tock and guys well it's actually guys on
YouTube that are taking chicks Tick Tock
videos about dating and compiling them
and just and then these women talking
about their date online dating profiles
I would never [__] get uh
get any girl off a dating profile
it's always going to be something you
meet in the wild
and if I'm especially if you're a guy
and especially if you're a guy that
ranges more towards the average guy or
maybe a little bit above average I've
seen the statistics on those dating apps
those are loser statistics man you'd be
better off in Vegas
and Vegas is a [__] Rob you're blind
on those apps
the top 10 of the guys are getting all
those girls and they're just running
through them and if you're one guy and
your DM is filled with [__] 20 or 30
hotties every [__] week why is he
gonna pick one of them he's going to
take them all
right and they're not picking the other
guys
so don't be on that dating app dating
app things don't train I wouldn't
translate on a dating app
you have to meet this [__] you gotta see
this [__] [__] in person
because I'ma [__] do some [__] you've
never seen before
that's true I'm gonna go to the club or
it's gonna have it's gonna be [__]
we're gonna be balling it's gonna be
[__] great
I got Club game gen with desk yeah I got
a [__] club yeah but I have fun yeah
you know and that that will never come
across in a on a dating app
these poor saps I'm listening to them
you know
trying to find a girlfriend in this
[__] they're in their 20s and 30s you
know which man of 20s is already rough I
mean the 20s for guys is rough uh
because you just can't compete against
guys within their 30s they get all the
girls they got they got more money than
you they're more established they're
more mature than you at 25 you're still
about [__] kind of a guy yeah guy
from from a women's point of view yeah
yeah you're very like childlike still
yeah that's why that's why I said [__]
this [__] I saw it coming
as soon as high school was over
two years later I was like man this
sucks out here I joined the army yes I
ran away from my early 20s and joined
the [__] military life and loved it I
don't think I'd recommend it today from
what I'm seeing and hearing the army of
[__] or any of the military
uh it's just [__] up it's not what it
was
uh probably will never come back
today if I was a young guy I'd be
joining [__]
be joining a motorcycle gang
you gotta hang out with those guys not
necessarily the out not necessarily a
[__] Outlaw motorcycle gang like uh
like like a warlocks we got warlocks
around here I run into them all the time
but the guys that are in the sport bike
gangs
they're not bad guys they got a lot they
got lots of girlfriends their
girlfriends ride with them if you go on
my Instagram you'll see them it's me
hanging out with them
I'd I'd I'd uh hang out with those guys
and that's more of a young male
environment they're having fun well I
have always more advocated and I'm not
saying there's anything wrong with like
dating apps because I know that some
people have actually found like you know
people on there that had [__] in common
with them but um I'm always kind of more
a big advocate of
you know go hang out with people that
are into the same kind of [__] as you
like whatever it is and try to meet a
person in that that way yeah I mean it's
easier for us maybe because we're in the
god scene and everybody knows everybody
and yeah you know what I mean it's like
if you see like a hot person you know
somebody that knows that person it's
like hey I'm gonna go like I'm introduce
me to that person or whatever but it's
just and you know that they have they're
into the same [__] as you but I would
always advocate
going someplace and hanging out with
people that are into the same [__] that
you're into yeah and meet somebody that
way here's the problem
a lot of the girls don't have any
any uh Hobbies
a lot of the young guys are pretty much
tied up with [__] work in video games
so they don't have much Hobbies either
according to the data that I'm hearing
so they're in a different Market
nobody's that generation evidently in
most of the United States doesn't go out
to clubs anymore
because I can't see that see we live in
Florida
and according to all my other sources
Florida is still pretty normal other
places of the of the US after this
coveted thing they never really quite
recovered you got people that are afraid
to go to clubs because they might get
sick just [__] like that evidently you
know but uh Florida is its own thing
people are moving here because it's
Florida
and the [__] that I put up in the clubs
here like at mannequins is not typical
of the rest of the United States
like we go to mannequins chances are I'm
gonna have to fight because some of them
dudes are gonna grab Jenny's ass that's
why we all know as much right so or I'm
gonna hit somebody yeah so because
they're annoying the [__] out of me
every time I go to Madison when I go to
mannequins
the chance I'm gonna have to fight at
least maybe a 75 yeah and there's a 50
chance that I might smack somebody yeah
one night I fought two guys there in a
night big guys
I was [__] I as hell on [__] Tran
yeah well [__] the [__] the goblin
at the time yeah just ran through him
like nothing
but it wasn't like they didn't have it
coming no they had common but then yeah
then I got that other guy kind of [__]
up had him kicked up got him to
challenge me to a fight right in front
of the security to get him kicked out
and I was kind of felt guilty about it
yeah you didn't feel guilty about it
afterwards but then I was like yeah but
that dude he had a comment though yeah
well I would have told you if he hadn't
had a comment if he was just some Rando
but he was just like he was being
annoying as [__] and somebody needed I
could have happened in a different way
yeah you could Tran had had Tran had a
hold of me I mean honestly like had you
not been there probably
um we would have just like
left yeah like or just tried to get the
[__] rid of him or I might have shoved
him not gonna lie so it's not like you
it came out of nowhere like I probably
would have ended up hitting him as well
because he was just kept fogging up if I
and he wouldn't go away and I can't
stand
when you tell somebody right to their
face like go away or get away from me
and they don't they just keep standing
there they keep coming back and I'm like
finally I have to be like you go away or
I'm going to hit you yeah and if you and
if you don't go away then then I am
going to hit you so Florida's like a
mixture Florida's not like the rest of
the United States especially right now
according
to what the data is saying on Tick Tock
and what these girls are saying and what
the data says is that in other parts of
the United States the women are
complaining the guys aren't approaching
them
that they're that they're too shy
they're not approaching so they're
becoming like these Japanese Guys these
they're vegetarian men non-florida
Florida these dudes here are aggressive
I was not in a bad way well sometimes
sometimes it is but a guys if you're at
a club and you know you you want to meet
that girl go over there meet her like I
said and I've said this before like I've
had dudes come I'm not like blowing my
own horn or anything like that but I
have had dudes like at mannequins and
stuff not so much a Barbarella because
nobody knows everybody there but at
mannequins where we have strangers
walking in I have had dudes come up and
offered by me a drink or like you know
try to chat me up and stuff like that
and I absolutely do not mind that I
don't mind that as long as when I say oh
no thank you or because I'm polite
at first yeah
um if you do not take no for an answer
or if I'm just like oh you know I'm with
somebody or no thank you I have a drink
or something like that like if you just
go oh you know that's fine and then you
just [__] off awesome you see that's
awesome but you stay there yeah and keep
persisting yeah then I'm gonna punch you
in the mouth yeah see or Tom is Gonna
Knock your head off see here's this
thing when it comes back here's the
thing
if a guy makes a hit on her and he's
slick about it I like that
yeah and like I said I don't mind it I
like it as long as you're cool about it
right I like it because it makes her
feel good that she's desired makes me
feel good the young guys are still
gunning for my girl so it's a ego thing
right
but they are slick them bastards they'll
wait till I go to the [__] restroom
well they almost always did and then I
go to the restroom and then I'll come
out and I'll see some dude chatting her
up and I'll just kind of hold back and
give Jen time to deal with it
and usually you know
gentle deal with it like a lady and the
dude's cool and just okay that's it most
of the time just like most of the time
they're cool yeah
like I said I am a nice person and I'm
not rude
um as long as they come up and they're
not you know obviously if they come up
and they're like obnoxious like oh nice
tits or something like that then I'm
just gonna hit you right in the face
yeah I'm gonna [__] you up too
you gotta have if you just come up and
you just like naturally I mean because
if he's in the bathroom or something you
just think I'm alone like and you come
up and like hey can I buy you a drink
and stuff like I am totally not offended
I'm not offended by that yeah and
neither am I you know just but you know
you grab her [__] grab her ass that's
what I mean somebody [__] touches me
without my then that's then I'm just
going straight to like hitting you if
she asks you to leave she doesn't want
to talk to you you won't go away I'm
gonna [__] you up yeah you know and I've
had that happen before like because you
know he and this was that I bar like a
while back yeah like you went in the
bathroom I think you were in the
bathroom yeah and I was just sitting
outside you know remember how ibar had
those little tables that were right
outside the bathroom and I was sitting
there waiting for you and three dudes
came up and like surrounded me like that
yeah and they just kept like sure I'm
just like yeah cool whatever I'm just
like you know I'm with somebody like
leave me and they just would not and I
was and finally I was just like go the
[__] away and they just stayed yeah I
came out I think they were already gone
by the time I came out huh well yeah
because then I got mad yeah
you wouldn't like me when I'm angry
and like I said you know we knew
everybody that worked there so it's like
if I complained to them they would have
thrown all of those dudes out but um
yeah I finally got them to leave but you
had it got to where they just let me
throw people out too now well yeah
because they're like well that dude must
have done yeah there's something wrong
yeah well that's the thing it's like it
just makes me mad it makes me mad that
like people won't listen to you like you
tell them like normally it's like oh no
thank you or you know I don't really
want to talk to you anymore right and
then they just keep yeah now let's let
me straight they keep hanging around
bring something out for the audience
this is not happening in clubs where
it's just like the goth scene like
that's where we're going tonight we're
going to barbarella's tonight yeah I
feel totally safe awesome all right
there's no troublemakers there well
there's no foot traffic because you have
to know where it is there's no signs
there's nothing you have to know exactly
where it is what we're talking about is
place that has high foot traffics and a
lot of walk-ins and they don't know what
kind of club they're in and they don't
know who they're talking to
you know that too they don't know
anybody yeah you'll have some dude
[__] try to make some move on some
chick who's dancing I'm going you
[__] idiot that chick is married to
that other chick she was dancing right
you know [__] because he hasn't taken
it because he does that now rule number
one [__] the warrior must understand
the battlefield you don't just rock into
a club and assume that everybody else is
just as new as you are those people that
dress cool they're in that scene they've
known each other for decades yeah and a
lot of them have slept with each other
yeah
so yeah that she's single but if you
look in the background there's three of
her exes back there yeah all of them
will go to go go to bat for that woman
if somebody yeah presses her you know
and all those three X's are better
friends with each other there's a bunch
of random people like a bunch of other
people that know her will jump in that
[__] too yeah yeah we've had that happen
too so somebody [__] with somebody like
that we know everybody the whole bar
yeah and jump on it you leave her alone
so you you know
you can't really throw your weight
around in there too much if you're not
known
yeah
yeah because everybody will be like who
the [__] are you yeah you gotta have you
get the management has to know you long
periods of time yeah
so I don't know so like I said and we've
said this before I don't really know I
don't really understand these dudes that
like just wander into a club and if we
don't know who the [__] you are and it's
like they act like they own the place or
some [__] yeah walking in like
everybody's like who the [__] are you I
was like or just grab some hottie by the
wrist come here
oh that's not gonna end oh yeah yeah
keep talking about that's not gonna end
well yeah imagine if somebody grabbed
like Shawna like that or something like
that she will bust your [__] teeth in
wait remember shirtless guy
yeah sure this guy [__]
when they when when defense came out to
do her act sure this guy was trying to
get all up on it like that and [__]
defense defends his boyfriend slash
security was trying to toss that dude
all out of the way just because he
didn't know who [__]
Jillian was yeah
you know he just thought she was another
client no she was a paid performer yeah
for the club because the clubs will pay
honestly if I was her I don't know if I
would want to perform there or not right
because that she did a cool show risky
yeah she did a cool show and [__] but
it's just like I would not
I would not because I know like our
friend Aurora has done like suspension
shows and stuff like that although she's
usually does them out back yeah so it's
not quite as bad out there but you can't
like because these people come in here
and like they think it's like oh if
you're performing or you look fetishy or
something like that they just think they
can do whatever the [__] they want to
you so they can touch you right and I'm
just like no that's not how that works
they don't really understand what it is
they're dealing with keep your guys the
only outside the only Outsiders that
actually behave pretty well
or very well actually in the god scene
where the warlocks
and honestly I don't have a problem with
biker gangs I would rather biker gangs
than frat Bros yeah any day of the week
biker gangs know what a subculture is
yeah and they usually come in if they
don't even if they don't like know the
music or anything like that they'll come
in and be like oh they get it yeah you
know what I mean and they just keep to
themselves yeah they sit there and they
drink they're just like ah this is kind
of cool and [__] like that they just
like I said that's all you got to do
just be chill yeah don't like come in
and act like you own the [__] place
don't come in and like try to like
groping on people and [__] like that
bikers understand seems easy understand
rake and hierarchy and social wreck and
social hierarchy because that's what
that's what micro gags are like that the
club called motorcycle clubs
so they just know it's a different kind
of a club yeah and they and then they
show up and then they're bringing their
mamas with them [__] dancing them on
[__] this stripper poles yeah they're
leashes and [__] [__] they're wearing
their colors and everything it's a
slightly different visual style it's
like a little bit like goth meets
country western you know kind of yeah
weirdly but yeah that cabinet at the
same time right but they got they got
along real well no no problems with them
and they if they see a half nude golf
chick they're not even shocked they're
like yeah that's what it should be
you know yeah they're not yeah they're
[__] a lot of The Proud boys are just
they're they're what the hell what the
[__] yeah they can't handle it
bikers are like yeah unless you got a
nice ass on her
it's just it you know yeah but they
won't they don't feel the need to like
touch that person or they'll appreciate
yeah and then they'll just be like go
back to their drink and I'm just like
that's a perfect situation yeah the
problem arises when somebody tries to
like fog up on that [__] yeah and tries
to like touch him and stuff please don't
do that
and I'm just saying I might need one oh
okay I'm gonna have one more drink I'll
give you a half okay it's 8 30. we can
be on for about another half hour okay
because we gotta leave yeah at 9 30.
because like I said we're going out to
momentum Warrior tonight out to
Barbarella which like I said
that's a much mannequins is fun but like
I said a lot of the times we're gonna
end up in a fight because
some [__] gonna come in there
and cause some trouble and we're gonna
have to
step in there and it's not just us it's
like [__] happens when we're not there
too that we hear about later
but nothing ever happens at Barbarella
because like I said there's where it is
actually when they moved to the club
because it used to be right like in the
middle of downtown and when they moved
it to where it is
even if we even when we had GPS the
first time we went there it took us a
while to find it because it's it's in
like a warehouse but it's in like this
big like maze-like Warehouse complex and
it's hard and there's no sign
there is no sign outside there is no
nothing
so it's like you have to know exactly
where it's at
um so you don't and there's not and it's
in the warehouse District so everything
around it is closed
um you know there's just nothing around
there nobody's walking around so
nobody's just gonna wander in you have
to go there on purpose so when you go
there it's a very very safe environment
because everybody that's there
you know knows people that are there
it's like they went there on purpose and
you don't get any randos showing up
um so it's much nicer I feel like much
safer going there like if for example
like some of the dresses that I wore
like like the dress that I wore to the
last Memento I guess I wore it to the
last Memento which was like red and like
apparently it's just like see-through
and I wore it and I said I would never
in a million [__] years wear that to
mannequins like and not because I'm
victim blaming or anything like that but
I was just like that would just be like
[__] asking for trouble wearing
something like that to mannequins what
so like that red see-through dress that
I wore them Memento last time yeah and I
was like but I don't I have no
absolutely no issue wearing that to
Memento because everybody knows me
everybody
you know it'll be fine and it was fine
well she wore a dress the whole side was
open both sides just yeah and there was
like nothing under it and there was like
nothing really good but it's that's what
I mean I would wear that to you know to
Barbarella to Memento in a heartbeat I
would never ever wear that to mannequins
yeah ever
yeah guys I'm trying to pull that
[__] back looking that's what I mean
it's like I just be out there dancing
and like people would be doing [__] like
that and it's just like I'm not I don't
have the patience for that like I said
I'd be having to hit people yeah
yeah I guess it's not coming tonight of
a [__]
I told you I think that happened before
it says it's out for delivery I know but
it said that it said that before and it
didn't come okay well it might come
tomorrow it's probably the dude's car
yeah he's just like I'm going home I'm
too tired to drop it off
comprehend how little it takes to rate
an assault charge yeah and honestly if
you make me mad enough I am absolutely
gonna press charges so
don't don't do that [__] can't you wait
for those to show up
yeah see those are cool yeah those are
one of the pairs of shoes that Tom got
me for my birthday
so I guess they're going to come
tomorrow now yeah
I'm digging the I'm digging the ankle
straps I go well because I got two pairs
of shoes from chin that had that were
like Mary Janes with all the metal and
[__] on them and they both have ankle
straps and they both look really good
because like I said the the stuff that
I'm on is making my legs really skinny
I couldn't wear this before because my
ankles were too because I can't I had
cankles but those kind of those kind of
went away now yeah no they're gone yeah
only took a couple weeks
when I looked at and I got those
yeah
I don't know how well I'm gonna be able
to walk in those but you're gonna work
enough I'm gonna work in those I'm gonna
I'm gonna streamate in those because
honestly when I did stream eight the
other day I had these shoes that they're
kind of like that but they don't have
the ankle thing
and um Tom loves them but I can't
[__] walk in them like they're super
super high Spike heel yeah and like I'm
just like I just look like a baby I got
a shoe finish but but I you know if I
can just put them on and they look good
as long as I have to get up and walk
around
so I wore those the other day but be
great in uh photo shoot
yeah photo shoot video they look awesome
yeah but I can't [__] walk in them I
think I wore them out one time a long
time ago yeah it killed you and it
killed my [__] feet
again your legs weren't as strong back
then as they are right now that's true
your legs are strong I mean I would
really have to walk around in them at
practice but she's been [__] killing
it in the gym
yeah getting her newbie Gates
no your legs just [__] some of you
guys seen the video
that we put out
on many many vids and stuff
Jen doesn't look like that anymore she's
cute in those videos she looks a lot
better now
you gotta be 30 pounds lighter I think
I've lost
um 25 or 30 pounds yeah
yeah a lot more shape
yeah physicality
just diet exercise on gear
I couldn't believe the posted um the the
photos that I posted on Facebook that
the lady took of us at the Courthouse
yeah like the marriage pictures
um I was like looking at him going oh my
god look how [__] skin yeah yeah
because I used to have little fat hobbit
legs they're they're hit chubby legs
yeah they're cute though a lot a lot of
girls have that you know and women your
age kind of tend to have that
um
for any women listeners I'm not a doctor
I can't give medical advice blah blah
blah blah yeah that's a disclaimer
that's a disclaimer
once you're beyond the age of 35 you
cannot get really a dramatic change in
your body structure
and your body makeup in terms of fat and
muscle
distribution you can't really make a big
difference after 35.
um no matter what you do
diet or exercise your body doesn't
really respond to it very much because
you don't really produce the hormones
that you use to produce
the androgens
and for women the main Androgen is
um
uh [__] [__] would
testosterone is one of them but the
other one was uh starts with a P
projection progesterone
progesterone does a lot of stuff for the
for the female figure
it kind of works a little bit like
testosterone does on a guy
um
now
estrogen's in there too but it's not
real critical
so if you want a dramatic change in your
body
like you want to go from basically being
dumpy to muscular or to real svelte or
like [__] aqualine
build you're gonna have to do hormone
replacement
because your hormones aren't really
being produced the way they were when
you were a teenager
so you have to replace those hormones
with synthetic copies
you define the right one is
can be tricky the book is going to say
to use things like anavar
but if you research and research and dig
into what doctors have done and what gym
rats have done as soon as those are
people just in gym they're dumb no those
big [__] are smart and a lot of
them [__] understand biochemistry uh
better than a biochemist all right uh
some of them [__] no Endocrinology
better than a a [__] family doctor
like doctors tell me all kinds of [__] I
know is wrong because I [__] read the
papers on it you know because they're
not endocrinologists
some of these guys that are trainers are
also [__] like I said scientists
endocrinologists and they're working out
taking all this [__]
the best thing that a woman can do
especially after menopause is uh takes
inject testosterone about 20 milligrams
a week
some kind of long Esther
that'll help
other doctors say that you can take you
can take that testosterone out of there
and replace it with natural loan 19 Nore
testosterone which is an improved
version of testosterone so that's
androgenic it it makes less male
secondary sex characteristics in other
words hair growth and [__] [__] like
that so that means you can give more 19
or testosterone than normal testosterone
and get away with it so it's like giving
a woman a real big bump of testosterone
and what that does is that commands
ourselves to start [__] the
mitochondria and the cells to start
working start [__] clearing out all
the junk start burning fat start
synthesizing protein that you eat and
turn it into muscle but it's not a thing
where it's not a drug where you just
take it and it happens
you're injecting a hormone that's
causing your body to work and then you
have to go train and you weight
resistance that's the best thing you
know lift lift weights
and then that'll activate the uh those
hormones into doing work well I don't do
it that much no couple times a week just
twice a week yep and it's not like a
huge deal yeah like I still hate it but
women are scared but it's not that big
of a deal they don't understand it
they'll do cardio but they don't
understand that [__]
eight hours of cardio is can can be
compressed into 15 minutes of lifting
weight basically
you know the amount of work that you did
you're lifting a heavy weight you've
concentrated all that all that work into
a very brief amount of time
and the body responds better to that
and it's more and like I said you can
get it over with
very quickly you know we gotta um we got
a bench today so that we could do well
one so we could do flies because Tom
wanted to do those but um also so you
could do that what do they call that the
exercises like a glute dress like you
put the put away the barbell across your
pelvis and then like
do your butt make your ass big to make
your ass big yeah so I was doing that
this morning yeah
I gotta do it too though yeah to match
my legs you got to do it too yeah it's
just men got to do upper ant body full
body workout
and well the and the bench that we got
we discovered was
um still a little too tall for me
because I am because I'm like I said a
hobbit yeah so I had to use the shorter
one yeah because I couldn't get
I can get up on it because I was too
little now
this is just how it is
if you're on gear and you're running
running gear the correct way
and the way it's done for men is
different than the way it's done for
women
no matter what you do as long as you're
eating and sleeping enough or the body
responds to it much faster than it would
be if say even when you were a teenager
probably half that
so twice that progress
but there's limits
not everyone responds exactly the same
way some people can't take these at all
you take gear and they [__] them up for
some reason
um
other people will hyper respond to it
they can take it and work out and get
much bigger than another dude who did
the same thing
all these body Pro bodybuilders open
class bodybuilders like on [__] the
Olympia when somebody thinks of a
bodybuilder they think these gigantic
dudes those muscles that's not the
normal guy
that's that's a perfect storm
of a do a good work ethic fantastic
jeans
great diet and he's working a lot
and he's and he's young too that that's
part of it and he started Young
you you could give me all those all
those steroids he took and did that same
diet and worked that same workout and I
never get as big as those guys
just the genetics aren't there yeah
well that's the things will never be
everybody is different yeah and like you
said like the people that you see that
rise to the top like that those are the
best of the best yeah and it's like you
know not everybody will look like
thousands of dudes that failed exactly
they couldn't get that big that's what I
mean um so don't expect it these women
think these women and guys too think
that you just inject something and the
next day you're huge oh I don't want to
get too big well everybody I don't if I
do this I might get to everybody wants
like an easy yeah it's not here and
that's goes back I mean that's just a
very human thing yeah I just started
laughing people want to diet pills
they're like they just wanted to pop a
pill and that's not exactly skinny but
no it's the same thing they'll have
these guys saying well I don't want to
do that because I'll get too big and you
can start start laughing no you won't
you won't even get a fraction of that
size
those dudes had perfect genetics and
they worked much harder than you ever
[__] dreamed of working to get they
had to force that into existence it's
not like it happened by accident oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa injected too much oh here
I can't remember
that's what they're thinking because
they're they're oh they're morons no
those dude you gotta this isn't the
Marvel Universe yeah
there's not just a thing you can ingest
that'll like turn you into like a
Monster yeah and then there's like these
girls who said well I don't want to work
out my legs I uh I might look too manly
like that happens overnight like you
went out there and did one too many
repetition and woke up the next morning
oh my God you know whoa no that takes
her bottle yeah oh my God I'm too
muscular it takes [__] years you see
it coming [__] a mile away yeah and
if you don't like it you don't like it
just stop working out right stop working
out
I mean honestly like I said what I've I
mean and I've done like I said twice a
week it's like I don't do huge weight or
anything like that but it's just like
that and the stuff you've given me it's
like it honestly made my legs just
a lot thinner yeah but like harder like
the muscle is like a lot harder so
they're not like super big or anything
it's called recomposition yeah they're
just thinner they've been re you've
recompositioned like I said I can't
believe how much thinner they got yeah
and it didn't take long now only a few
weeks actually yeah like ever since I
started it's because it works now yeah
everything sits you know I mean the
hormones everything it works now
whatever you do well like I said ever
since I started taking that stuff and
like you know working out a little bit
it's just it really I think I've lost
like 25 or 30 pounds like in the last
few months yeah
because I've been weighing and I have
I'm pretty sure I've lost at least
because your metabolism is moving yeah
I've been eating last two yeah there's
that yeah but you see you can't
you can be in a caloric caloric deficit
and be on gear and not lose any muscle
he'll just lose just fat yeah you won't
lose any muscle it can't do it it can't
go catabolic you can't you can't Capital
catabolism can't happen under that
conditions now some people think that
when you're talking about gear it
doesn't matter what kind of stero it is
you're talking about or testosterone
which they're all the same thing they're
all synthetic copies of
they think that uh
uh oh [__] I forgot where I was going
I'm going that's what I was getting that
yeah you you interrupted me no because I
I just said you said I gotta go
what was I talking about let me go look
at the comment section
oh what I was saying is a lot of people
think that this gear
comes from [__] basement Laboratories
like some dude made somewhere some kid
made it these come from these come from
repentable
um Laboratories overseas uh in countries
where it's legal you can get it from
there
and there's ways to get it there's
services that can get it to get it to
you and um
you can make it here there's ways to
make it you can do the the chemicals
that you use to make all that stuff
commonly available just have to know
what you're doing you can make
testosterone and you can make 19 North
testosterones it's pretty simple
chemistry it's not made out of anything
really exotic either and or expensive
but
so the stuff you're getting is a lot
better than people than Street just
people on the street think it is they
think it's some kind of a [__]
weird highly dangerous chemical that
you take and you blow up like the Hulk
or some [__] like that
doctors have been prescribing this [__]
going back to the [__] 50s
and uh one of the main uses was a couple
equal
the main uses of most of these anabolics
is things like people that have been
burned badly you can give them that
um somebody who's been busted up in a
car wreck or they're trying to recover
from a surgery
you can give them uh steroids now
testosterone is like a steroid same
thing well steroids are just modified
testosterone but they've taken the
secondary sex characteristics in other
words the the stuff that makes you grow
a beard to take it away off of it so you
can give it to a child or a woman
without turning them into a man
and but you still get that accelerated
healing
the [__] was not made for you to get
giant that's a bad misconception
it was made
to speed healing
and what that means is that you can go
into a gym and work out
and heal up within 12 hours and go out
and do it again
and do it again and then do it again if
you want to
or sometimes you can just just enough to
stimulate muscle and then just eat a
bunch of protein and you'll just heal up
and grow a bunch of muscle
it makes it um faster
and uh if your jeans are good
you'll get a bigger better shape than
you ever would have doing it naturally
without anabolics especially after the
age after the age of 35.
I don't really endorse you doing this
[__]
if you're in your teens or your 20s
you should have enough testosterone just
being naturally produced in your body if
you're healthy
to get good results during that time
so they call them natties natural guys
now if you're in a [__] pro athlete
you're gonna be on steroids they're all
all of them are including Bowlers and
[__]
dudes that are playing baseball and
people go that's [__] they they drug
test yeah yeah they do steroid tests
right before the game but in the off
season when they're training they're on
[__] steroids
the Train on steroids and then you bring
you get off of them before the test and
depending on which ones you're taking
you know natural on them could take a
couple months to get out of your system
but [__] like MPP would be out of your
system about three or four days
so no they're on steroids when they're
training
and uh you're a child if you think
that's not happening
yeah all of them are on and those
endurance Runners around Winstrol I can
you know that's why they look so wiry
and so are the [__] bite those bike
riders the speed bike riders when
they're in the off-season training
they're on [__]
it'd be stupid not to not to
because they got their whole careers are
riding on that
they just have to pass the test before
the race or before the game that's it
it's easy to pass that
Camp guy said I thought your legs looked
great on Wednesday when you got up and
walked around well thank you yeah it's
weird they they changed a lot like just
in the last few weeks yeah
Poe says why doesn't Tom do a show about
this stuff he's always talking about it
willy-nilly when I consolidate
yeah doing a channel is a lot of work
and they got so many good channels
already up there
you'd be good at that though I feel like
I'd be a good guest
you think on those shows oh that maybe
that's what you should do yeah I'd be a
good guess you could like you should
like approach some of them and like well
I don't have I don't have a professional
bodybuilding career though that's true
if I if I was if I was a pro bodybuilder
or ex Pro body builder I'd get on there
no problem
but I'm just I'm just a [__]
I'm on sport HRT sport
hormone replacement for Old guys
and honestly I kind of feel like I'm
sort of a guinea pig too because I'm
kind of like you've been injecting me
with stuff and I don't even ask what it
is yeah but yeah because everything I've
given you is standard out of the book
for what females take well that's yeah
that's what I mean that's why I'm not I
trust you you know you wouldn't give me
anything that would work anavar Winstrol
and then those and like I said those
didn't really do but that doesn't mean
it doesn't do stuff for other people it
just didn't do anything yeah each person
is different their reaction is gonna be
different the only thing that I
immediately responded to was this [__]
yeah well then I gave her a little bit
test but I was just doing test at
replacement level right because
post-menopausal women should be taking
20 milligrams of tests yeah and it just
kind of helps keep the body well I think
if you're on like hormone replacement
therapy after you go through menopause
that's what they give you yes a lot of
doctors will yeah they give that to you
anyways not a lot of the [__] hormone
Shacks like the ones that I started off
in they don't want to they don't even
want to [__] with females all right
because females tend to complain a lot
we're the worst yeah they'll say well
this didn't work on it and they're
really afraid of lawsuits yeah
so they don't [__] with females at all
you got to do it on your own
um just well women are complicated
that's usually how they well the women
are well it's not just that women are
complicated I mean we are yeah but
another thing too is that a lot of and
this is [__] up but a lot of medical
studies were done on men
and a lot of them have been done on
women and a lot of the drugs work on
women differently but they don't have a
large enough sample size to like tell
you what the deal is here's the problem
if you're a post-menopausal woman and
you try to mimic the hormonal profile of
a teenage girl
so you start to look and act a little
bit more like a teenage girl probably a
lot of stress on on the female system
that's a lot of stuff you have to
[__] inject good Lord and I'm not
sure because it's it's going to be a
mixture of testosterone progesterone and
um and uh estrogen and it's going to
have to be the right combinations of
them at the right times
and
I don't think to turn your cycle back on
but you're going to start behaving like
a teenage girl again and what will
happen is those girls will complain
about it because they get all emotional
or something then they go back to the
doctor with a lawsuit that that's made
me feel funny
well yeah we put you
and it's the same thing with test really
you should have tests
uh it's a lot easier for postmenopausal
women
[__] all that [__] trying to turn her
back into a teenage girl I wouldn't want
to be turned back yeah just just give
her a little bit and I was pretty chill
I wasn't like super emotional or nothing
right it's better just to [__] give
her a little bit of test to help her
keep weight off because I don't want my
period back though absolutely not that's
easy to do no thank you no thank you
really a woman should have it turned on
a couple times a year no thank you it
refreshes your skin too I know she don't
want to hear me no thank you kind of
like why are you running from something
that you used to do all every month for
your your whole that's exactly why
because I think it was [__] sick
do you know how many decades that was
you can give a woman that was a test and
it'll help her keep weight off of her
but a lot of hormone Shacks the doctors
don't want to do it because they're
afraid that she'll come back going I
grew a little bit of hair here I'm gonna
sue you because that could happen yeah
just [__] shave it a little bit be
all right [__] pull it
well I kind of feel like a lot of women
even young women you have facial hair
yeah fishing right you just wax it or
whatever or they come back and goes my
voice got rougher I'm gonna sue you and
I'm like well yeah honestly I think
you're tough now that was the thing that
bothered me the most I think when you
started giving me this stuff because
that was really the only side effect
that I had was that my voice got a lot
deeper yeah and rougher I kind of
sounded like yeah I kind of sounded like
an old broad didn't like smoked for a
bunch of years because smoking yeah God
damn it I got it I went back in it the
thing with that the thing sounded like
that the thing with that is that is that
I kind of still sound like that actually
that's actually temporary I know
you come off of it it doesn't bother me
as much if you come off of it you know
six months later it's over over a few
months it starts to fade
because it had that has to your vocal
cords have been kind of thickened up a
little bit everything's been thickened
up a little bit [__] when you take
tests not much this is like a drop among
other things we're not gonna say what
the other thing is
you know what I'm talking about yeah oh
yeah yeah
that's a good side
he likes that I kind of like that yeah
there are sexual side effects to all
this yeah that's all we're gonna
increase female sexual aggression
[__] um
certain parts of the anatomy get bigger
uh [__] which like I said I'm kind of
into that yeah it's nothing like it you
know it's not weird or nothing like that
it's not like right right y'all y'all
are watching porn see it well [__] you
can see her [__] you know we got
videos but you're watching porn you see
it all the time in other women a lot you
know a lot of times it's natural a lot
of times it isn't it's almost most of
those porn stars that are real hot
around here
and you seem to like you seem to really
like it I can imagine yeah you seem to
like it makes everything easy
it does yeah
um
Tammy said we're all adults here we know
what you're talking about
it's nothing out of the ordinary no it's
not it's not crazy or nothing like that
but it's probably like I'm gonna say
um it's probably like
um 50 bigger 75 bigger maybe twice as
big twice okay
twice yeah maybe you're right yes twice
maybe you're right
um
but not a bad thing no because uh there
are girls I know that are even bigger
than that and they're they're natural
yeah
that could happen during female puberty
yeah if they have a real if they're
athletic if they're in high school and
they're doing uh doing a lot of athletic
activities you know they're [__]
playing volleyball or [__] you know
swimming or uh gymnastics and uh
puberty's [__] coming on strong that
physical activity makes it puberty even
stronger they get more hormones in there
and they kind of get that look which is
sexy that's a sexy look you know they
become very
uh um alpha female you know
and Tom kind of likes that yeah
you have all this strong independent
women that's all [__] I like a real
strong woman woman [__] muscles yeah
[Laughter]
yeah baby you know
I look you know feminine beauty comes in
all different
types you know but that's one of them I
I like female bodybuilders some of them
Jenny knows what I'll show Jenny yeah
some of them are turn out
uh no but some of them are very
attractive I mean his Instagram feed uh
if you look through it it's just it's a
it's a weird combo oh yeah of like
weightlifting chicks like like real
muscle bound chicks yeah and then like
super femi yeah Cosplay chicks yeah fat
girls fat girls he likes kind of
everything yeah there's a certain kind
of fat girl I like though yeah
big ass big thighs big boobs skinny
waist you know
cankles and everything little bitty feet
I just a short [__] dumpy but sexy
yeah and it's got to be something out of
the ordinary like I showed Jen that
what's his name Shady Shady Ray I think
her name is Shady Shannon Ridge this
just just yeah I can't remember this is
what yeah I remember who you're talking
about though and uh she's just uh
extremely extremely voluptuous it's hard
to believe that you can still have a
shape
and be that big I don't know how much
she weighs but I don't know I don't
think she weighs that much she probably
weighs about probably about once 180.
I would think more than that but well I
think she's probably a 411. oh okay so
she's a lot shorter she's little yeah
she's little and she's just real
see if I can show her a Dharma but no
there are certain fat girls I think are
[__] astounding but they're not the
norm
I kind of like outliers
yeah I like novelty women I guess
novelty women yeah I think that'd be a
good way to put it
[Laughter]
I mean you just you like standard hot
women too yeah yeah as long as they the
only thing that you don't like obnoxious
women well you don't like obnoxious
women and you don't seem to like skinny
women no or flat women no
like women that are just like real
skinny yeah no with no boobs no he
doesn't seem to be into that no because
all of the I noticed that because we
watch a lot of porn while we're doing
streaming and stuff yeah and I noticed
that all the porn stars names that he
remembers are yeah are big girls yeah
yeah I mean not big not fat but like big
asses and like big boobs like the skinny
one it's the skinny ones he's like yeah
I know everybody I forgot her name yeah
it's like I've seen her before but I
don't know
he's
not I'm just like I said I'm kind of
more
I don't know I like a person's Vibe more
than what they look like kind of but
yeah I don't know it kind of depends
what they look like
Victor says last week when your show was
over it auto played to an older show and
your voice was a lot higher yeah yeah I
didn't really realize
um when it happened until we were out at
the club and our friend Angel who
watches our show sometimes
she said oh I watched one of your older
shows and your voice was like way higher
than it is now yeah and it's like you
need to get off that [__] like she told
me but I was just like no it's fine I
mean honestly
yeah I've had a couple people comment
that they thought I was a dude but
like I said I'm not offended I'm just
I think it's kind of funny but that's
the girl I was talking about it's all
white okay oh yeah yeah
see he likes that kind of [__] too
he looks that kind of [__] too
she's heavy set but I like her yeah
he's working that yeah I mean she's
working she's got
that's that I'm gonna say that that's
significantly more than 180 pounds I
think she's little though yeah but I'm
saying maybe two even then yeah
because I think at one point I weighed
180 pounds okay and I was not that big
but I'm I'm taller than her maybe I
don't really know I mean I'm five foot
three I'm pretty short
so I think you're taller than her I
think she's little yeah
180. still though I don't know yeah it's
hard you know and and the girl that was
talking about said come off that [__]
don't listen to words she's [__] said
if you saw this girl you wouldn't listen
to her
[Laughter]
well like I said I hadn't even thought
about it until it's just it didn't kind
of bother me but I didn't really think
about it that much but then she said
something about it and then I got all
like yeah but it's insecure about it
it's not as rough now as it was then
though that's true it has gotten a
little bit better softened backed up
because and what that was is that was
Winstrol yeah and I'm not winstrol's
kind of known is a DHT derivative that's
one of the things that's kind of known
for is to get a real raspy voice
on women yeah but like I said it's not
permanent
and I thought to go back I would have
thought I mean I thought I still sounded
like I I don't think I sound like a man
no you're within the female range so
there's a lot of girls that sound like
you right
I mean I understand that right look
here's something else so many people get
upset about this
we were we were uh at the coffee shop
the other day and had this couple behind
us
a little short fat couple
and I thought it was two women back
there laughing and it wasn't it was a it
was a
it was a woman and her husband
and every time that [__] husband
would [__] open his mouth but it was
like for me it was like [__] Nails on
a chalkboard
it just sounded [__] horrible
this dude must have had [__]
very very low testosterone very low
it sounded like a woman back there
and he was in his 30s
it's overweight little overweight guy in
his 30s just horrible honestly but
here's the thing some of these comments
are coming from dudes like that
well see that's why I'm not bothered
yeah well honestly like if a long time
ago it probably would have bothered me
but nowadays I'm just kind of look I'm
old now
we've been doing like online [__] for a
long time I went through the whole I ran
the gauntlet of like shitty comments and
stuff and then like you just get to a
point where you just like one who the
[__] are you like whose pathetic ass is
like commenting on somebody they don't
know like who would waste their time
commenting on something like like why
would you do that like it just seems
really sad well it makes sense when you
see him that's what I mean so it's like
it just seems really pitiful
so I just I well I would say I feel
sorry for them but I don't
but I'm just saying I don't really think
about them at all because why would I I
don't know this [__] people
even if I did know them I wouldn't give
a [__] what they thought
like I said that's the coolest thing
about getting old you don't give a [__]
what people think anymore it's awesome
that's the single best thing and I think
every old older person will say that
single best thing
but yeah I don't I don't know I don't
mind my voice anymore
it did bother me at first but I don't it
doesn't really bother me anymore
you know
I don't know why we're even talking
about it well I don't think it's a big
deal no but well we can talk about this
chick right here check right there yeah
there's buckar nabit nabiva all right
she's on a bunch of gear
all right and her voice is about twice
as deep as yours yeah okay and [__]
dudes are all over that
and but her boyfriend is [__] huge
huge [__] bodybuilder
this is like one of the newer white
newer female bodybuilders that kind of
look like that
her legs are amazing
all right so there's certain sacrifices
if you're gonna start to get kind of a
supernatural [__] look where there's
just a lot of muscle and you're very a
lot of lean a lot of leanness to you
you're gonna be on [__] that's gonna
[__] make you sound strong and tough
okay and it's gonna because your vocal
cords are gonna thicken right I can do
things now with my voice I could have
never done this I'm going on down gonna
see my girl
I'm gonna sing a song I'm going to show
her my ding dong
that one
coming soon from Spotify yeah
and it also even that is not all that
constant remember how I sanded on Trend
yeah yeah what like psychopath yeah well
nonetheless just a [__] voice sound
like a [__] snarl yeah yeah you were
like growling all the time yeah
[Laughter]
we sort of want to go back on that oh I
[__] all the time
that was a hell of a drug
but I told you and like I said we I he
sent me like a video the other day of
like people talking about it
like just like a compilation of
different interviews people talking
about it bodybuilders talking about it
and one of them said exactly the same
thing they said that one it made him
think that his wife was cheating on him
all the time
um which he thought that too and um made
him act like a crazy person and he said
because the guy asked him like the
interviewer asked him is like well
didn't your wife say that you weren't
allowed to take anymore he's like no no
she didn't say I wasn't allowed to take
it she just said that if I took it she
was gonna leave me yeah which amounts to
the same thing I got yeah
but yeah that's what I was you know look
I'm not gonna stop anybody from doing
what they want to do if you want to do
it again you can but honestly I'm
probably gonna tie you to the bed at
night so you don't shoot me or something
or eat my face off yeah
well because I don't know it makes you
act like really erratically yeah and I
know that you told me after the fact
that it's like oh well I never would
have hurt you like you didn't yeah but
you were acting so crazy that it's like
how the [__] was I supposed to know that
when you say okay because you were
acting like such a nut that I was just
kind of like holy [__] he's gonna
[__] kill me no you know what I mean
now here's the thing the audience is
hearing this and their imaginations are
running wild I was not beating her no no
that's what I mean you never know
anything like that never even [__]
raised my really voice to her now
um [__] um never made any threats or
anything so you gotta be [__] clear
because yeah people [__] run
she was afraid
that I was gonna because I was fighting
guys a lot that was another thing I was
afraid you were just gonna kill somebody
and go to prison you're right yeah and
then it's on the second like you know on
the second tier I was afraid well maybe
he'll direct it at me it never yeah but
it never was but like no it was never
directed it's actually real protective
but I didn't know that yeah you know
what I mean I didn't know you should
have known because you were acting so
nutty you should have known because all
I was doing was protecting you the whole
time you know you become hyper masculine
but not in a human way almost like in an
animal way
where you're trying to protect the nest
and you're female
basically real Predator it's it's it's a
19 North testosterone but it's a it's a
different ester of it
when it originally came out it was for
human use but then they had they just
people couldn't handle it so they took
it off the market they made it for uh
veterinarian use only so they give it to
cattle
they give it to cattle before they sent
him off a Slaughter that way when
they're up on the train and they're
going to the slaughterhouse they don't
lose any weight because they may not be
eating for the next couple days
but um because it you can make lots of
it quickly it's cheap Trent's cheap a
lot of bang for your bucks is five times
more anabolic and five times more
androgenic than an equal amount of
[__] testosterone it's
and you're I was probably taking a
couple hundred milligrams of it a week
on top of testosterone and other stuff
I don't ever think I went to a gram or a
thousand milligrams per week on that
stack but
you're okay for about three months I was
on it for five months
because the the
maximum time you're supposed to be
honored is three months
but I felt so good I said [__] them what
do they know I'm fine I'm gonna continue
going
so I kept going for another time
that month four and five was kind of a
slow descent into [__] hell into
madness yeah you start becoming
basically like the gobbler yeah you were
like a Superman like a super villain
yeah you're thinking like uh you know I
think it's time I should kill that guy
you know this is weird yeah yeah we'd be
like driving around like we we pulled
out of our driveway oh my God that guy's
head off and like some dude just like
did some dumb thing or whatever and he's
just like and he's just like yelling out
the window with the dude and he's gonna
fight and I'm like oh my God I'm just
I'm not here I'm not yeah yeah
now
there's all this
there's all these rumors of [__] Roid
Rage
there's no such thing except Trent
they should call it Trend rage yeah and
I think maybe that's what they were
talking about trend's been around for a
long time yeah it could be that it could
be what they're talking about
because I feel like steroids in general
don't yeah do that kind of [__] yeah you
know but that does that one does it
doesn't do it to everybody no but it did
it to you and it and it's done it to
enough people it does the thing about it
it does it to most guys yeah but here's
the thing the guys that say oh I have
any problem with it man I don't know
what you're talking about let's just
probably live alone
and no one else to tell yeah because
that's another thing that was fun that's
what's Insidious about it is that you
you feel awesome yeah and you feel like
man I'm on top of the world yeah but
everybody around you is like oh my God
you're acting like a [__] psychopath
right now so if you don't have like a
bunch of people telling you that you
probably think you're doing fine and you
can just like keep on trucking yeah so I
think that's what what that might be the
problem so that could be what it is
because the fact that you had other
people around being like bro yeah
why what are you doing
it's made bodybuilders do weird [__]
over the years you know like a big Lenny
I think his name is Big Lenny I think
they were this crazy [__]
washed up kind of bodybuilder
old guy I mean he got on that [__] next
thing you know he's making [__] porn
interracial [__] porn on on tread and
uh
and then [__] that other guy that I
know is in the porn industry so I can
help only do gay porn on trend
yeah yeah
no claims to be straight
I don't really understand it I don't I I
don't think a straight guy could do that
well I don't know like that again Trent
is a [__] powerful [__] world of
that too and um and it kind of makes you
want to [__] everything yeah you don't
really care yeah what it is yeah and
what he's doing is kind of basically
like kind of like BDSM type stuff right
yeah yeah so
I guess I guess maybe Tran I guess you
can do it on Trent
a straight guy can [__] flip over and
become a [__] leather daddy real
quick imagine if you'd have been on
trend for longer you might have been
doing that [__] yeah maybe he might have
he [__] your hormones all up yeah it
does
and then eventually your mind starts
becoming very Twisted Victor says meth
also seems to make straight dudes suck
dick no yeah it probably does yeah I can
imagine yeah I mean this is Florida
there's a lot of meth heads down yeah I
know it's like the Midwest too there's a
lot of meth heads there
Camp guy said uh I like the anorexic
ballet dancer look that and I like some
of the mature ladies as well and gals
with British accents especially if
they're telling you what to do oh
I love that okay like but at the point
by the British accent it's like loss and
you're around [__] Camp guy said it
would be funny if some dude from England
said he liked girls with soft Southern
Accents like my wife and Jenny yeah
there probably is some like that when I
was over there they um a lot of them
liked my accent yeah although a lot of
them thought that I sounded Irish for
some [__] yeah I got the same thing
in Boston yeah yeah yeah which I don't
think my I don't and I you know I'm from
Florida originally so I do have a bit of
a Southern accent I imagine but it's
like I never in a million years would
have thought I sounded anything like an
Irish person but in Wales they
apparently did think that I'm not really
sure because the Welsh accent and the
Irish accent is quite different yeah if
you've never heard them next to each
other yeah but no about the voice your
voice is still in the female range it's
just that a lot of the guys that don't
know what the female range is you
haven't heard Chelsea if you're here
Chelsea talk she's not she's not in the
female range anymore
she's in the mail range
yeah but she's a [__]
240 pound [__] pure muscle [__]
bodybuilder like [__] five [__]
say if you made fun of her voice she
would just pound you into a crimson
underground yeah she's she's much
stronger than the average guy she she
doesn't give a [__] she's probably
stronger she's just like ah she's
probably stronger than three or four
average guys
um
but what I'm saying is is that when you
see her
you don't expect a real feminine voice
to come out of her anyway
that's true you know what I mean so that
would be kind of weird if yeah
Disney princess or something the girl
just showed the audience with the long
hair bakar her voice is rougher than
yours not I'll let you hear it all right
I'll let you hear it that was Winstrol
she was doing that too
but it might have softened recently
because last time I heard it was a
couple years a couple years ago
when she used to talk on the video she
hasn't talked she doesn't talk much
anymore yeah
um but no it's a kind of a growly
she's [__] enhanced though you know
uh
more like dealing with a leopard than a
woman yeah
every time I'd love to get a piece off
about it
you're getting a piece of that time
I'm gonna take you with me Jen well yeah
don't leave me at home
you're gonna help I don't get left
behind no no Dave just showed up okay
what's up Dad hello Mr and Mrs Ross he
says yeah hey I know he commented on the
photo he's like I think he was one of
the people that said about time a lot of
people said about time yeah we're gonna
get ready to uh go to mannequins here in
a minute not mannequins uh
Memento Mori is tonight so yeah what
time is it it's 9 18. we gotta go so
yeah I gotta well all like I said all I
gotta do is get dressed put my boots on
and feed the kitties let me go check the
door again and then he's got to check
the door but yeah so we gotta get out of
here because we're going out tonight
kind of I don't know have a little bit
of Celebration I guess
of the of the nuptials yesterday uh so
yeah hopefully you guys had a good time
listening to us ramble about [__] as
usual like we do on Friday and um we'll
be back on Monday talking about a movie
I don't know which one it is yet I was
um our friend Brian wanted us to do
dragged across concrete because he
worked on it
um and I've been wanting to see that
movie anyway so we might be doing that
one or we might be doing a couple other
ones that he recommended we'll see we'll
watch something over the weekend and
we'll talk about some [__] on Monday so
thank you everybody for dropping by
thanks for your congratulate
congratulations I can talk for real
um thank you for all your super chats
and we will see you guys again on Monday
good night